jess is with us in Springfield
Massachusetts hi Jess how are you I'm
good how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up I'm trying to I'm
thinking about consolidating my student
loans
I paid off like fifteen thousand last
year on them and I still have about 22
thousand last 22 three plus and I have
four federal little one or not little
they are twelve thousand and then I have
two privates which are ninety five
hundred and I didn't know if I should
consolidate them and do like a variable
or a fixed rate and I still have about
five thousand on a car left
you cannot consolidate government and
private they won't go together but you
can do to the to the two government ones
and the only reason to do that would be
if you got a lower rate have you gotten
a quote yeah I can get a variable at
four or a fixed at five to seven and
right now my two private student loans
is four thousand at five percent and
then five thousand at nine percent that
the four percent variable wasn't for
private was it yeah it was
what's the fix on the private uh the
fixed would be around five or seven
percent five to seven percent okay well
you've already got five fixed right yeah
okay well we wouldn't go up yep the only
reason to consolidate is to save on
interest it would never be you never go
up in interest because if you take two
individual loans the total ninety five
hundred and you pay a thousand dollars a
month on that or you take one loan
that's ninety five hundred you pay a
thousand dollars a month on that it pays
off in exactly the same period of time
if it's exactly the same interest rate
so two loans into one is never a reason
to consolidate any time but you might do
it if it saved you interest now here's
the thing you're not going to save on
this to buy a cup of coffee let's say
you saved one percent on ninety five
hundred how fast you're gonna have this
22,000 paid off
one year probably 14 months yep yep okay
so half of the year the 9500 is gone
right and so yeah I was probably gonna
pay the federal either way you're saving
you're saving six months of interest and
at one percent and so we're talking
about forty bucks it just doesn't make
any one percent of nine hundred is
ninety five dollars for the whole year
okay mm-hmm that's all you're saving and
you're not gonna save me more than that
because I would never go to variable I
would only do fixed and in that case
you're not gonna save enough money to
mess with this so I think you're the
secret sauce interest rates not your
problem the fact that you're pissed off
at debt and beaten in the face and
hitting it with a bat and cutting it
with a knife that's why you're gonna win
get violent it's not yeah it's just it's
just not interest rate mathematically
it's 40 bucks so we're talking about it
just it's not it's not worth the trouble
I wouldn't screw with it if I were you I
would just just get mad turn it up cut
cut back on something around the house
and listen to knock it out as fast as we
can I think you're 14 months sounds
about right let's get her done it's that
simple
it's that hard it's that easy it's not
difficult that's what it comes down to
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind